a report came out that a conservative
majority on the united states supreme
court is ready to overturn roe v wade
and uproot decades of precedent
affirming of decades of precedent
affirming a woman's right to an abortion
that's chuck schumer speaking about a
leaked draft of a court opinion
originally obtained and reported by
politico
the draft which was circulated among
justices in february suggests that the
court is poised to overturn the
decades-old decision on the right to
abortion shortly after the leak the
supreme court released a statement
confirming the document's authenticity
but added that it did not represent a
decision by the court what we're seeing
is a snapshot and it could change even
though it's written in this very
polished way that makes it look like a
final opinion writing an important legal
opinion which is going to have
an effect on the whole country
takes a bit of time the leaked draft
represents one step in a process that
can involve months of deliberation
here's a look at how the supreme court
makes decisions on cases and how their
rulings affect lawmaking in congress
once the supreme court accepts a case
justices review briefs and hear oral
arguments from both sides
in december the court heard oral
arguments for dobbs versus jackson
women's health organization a case that
considers a state law in mississippi
seeking to ban abortion after 15 weeks
as part of the case the court is
considering whether roe vs wade should
be overruled within days of an oral
argument the justices hold a private
meeting known as the conference where
they explain their views on a case and
take a straw vote or preliminary vote on
the ruling the senior justice and the
majority decides who writes the court's
opinion which is a written explanation
of what they decided and the reasoning
behind it in this case justice samuel
alito was assigned to write the draft a
majority opinion of the supreme court
decides what the law is in the united
states it's the last word
when it comes to interpreting the united
states constitution the majority opinion
is the only one that holds legal weight
but justices can write individual
opinions explaining their stance those
who agree but have additional ideas can
write a concurring opinion and those who
disagree can draft a dissenting opinion
those opinions circulate through the
court and justices decide whether or not
to sign on to them this process can last
several weeks or months during this time
they give feedback on the wording of the
opinion and the document can be edited
from people in the majority they're
going to be saying what they like what
they don't like what they want to see
emphasize what they think is going too
far
that kind of thing
and they'll send notes or corrections
they'll make suggestions
sometimes during that process
a justice can lose a majority while it
doesn't happen often justices have
changed their minds while the opinion
was being drafted in 2012 chief justice
john roberts initially voted to strike
down the affordable care act but
ultimately came to see the law as
constitutional that's which changed the
outcome to a 5-4 vote upholding the
statute things can change
up until the last minute
you know until the court
officially formally publicly releases an
opinion
it has not made a decision at least five
out of nine justices need to sign on to
approve the opinion the draft is kept
completely private until this point then
it is released to the public and treated
as constitutional law which federal and
state legislatures are bound to follow
sometimes when the supreme court makes a
decision
there is a reaction and congress takes
some steps to respond to what the court
has done if the draft opinion in dobbs
versus jackson women's health
organization holds it will be the rare
instance where the court rescinds a
right it previously has recognized what
this decision is purporting to do is to
take away a prior supreme court decision
recognizing a constitutional right and
that constitutional right restricted
what legislatures could do be it state
legislatures or congress if the majority
of justices sign on to the opinion
abortion restrictions that have
previously been unenforceable under roe
like those in florida texas and michigan
could start being enforced some states
could act to preserve the right to
reproductive choice lawmakers in new
york and california said that they would
push to amend their state constitutions
to cement existing laws that protect
abortion rights senate majority leader
chuck schumer has stated democrats
intention to codify roe versus wade at
the federal level but any bill faces
major hurdles in a divided congress it
is my intention for the senate to hold a
vote on legislation to codify the right
to an abortion in law if the supreme
court were to overrule roe versus wade
um
that's a kind of unusual situation
because you know it's very hard to think
of a time that the court recognized an
individual right
and then took it away
and then people who still wanted that
right had to enact it legislatively the
court has until the end of june to make
a final decision and experts expect that
abortion will be one of the final
rulings before the court takes a break